he took aim at your weight what was your
reaction to that oh well like he Summit
on us
um I mean please uh you know look Howie
there are tens of millions of Americans
out in your audience watching right now
who like me have struggled with their
weight true I continue to struggle I
continue to try to do better
um and so do they and what's that got to
do with my confidence for office I ran
the governorship of New Jersey for eight
years I think in a very energetic
successful way responded to Hurricane
Sandy working 20 hours a day for weeks
um I don't know what his point is you
know what it is it's like a child it's a
bully on the schoolyard who teases you
and makes fun of you but here's my
message to him I don't care what he says
about me and I don't care what he thinks
about me and he should take a look in
the mirror every once in a while maybe
he dropped the weight thing the cult
followers allow you to criticize others
for things that are also characteristics
about you